[موسيقى]
بين اكوام الكتب ورائحه الاوراق بين احبار
الاقلام والضوء الخافت يختار المفكر ان
يقضي جل عمره في عالم القراءه والغرق في
البحث
وبين ما يواصل رحلته في البحث والتعبير عن
افكاره منتظرا ان تترك اثرا في مجتمعه لا
يجد المفكر من يفند انتاجه الادبي او من
يحاجج افكاره بافكار
لا يجد الا محاكم تفتش عن نوايا
واحكاما بالكفر لا نقض فيها او دفاع
الخوف موجود في كل في كل مكان يعني اذا
انت بتخاف عليك انك تخاف من الحياه يعني
لانه الحياه مليئه بالمخاطر مش هتخاف بقى
من اي يعني موتور يعني يمسك خنجر ويتعمل
زي ما حصل نجيب محفوظ كمان جزء من من
استمرار في العمل الحقيقي اني عمري ما عشت
بالخوف ده
[موسيقى]
لايدن المدينه الهولنديه الساحره الواقعه
الجنوبيه البلاد على ارضها تحتضن اقدم
الجامعات الاوروبيه التي تاسست عام
1571 وتحمل اسم المدينه نفسها
بين ملامح الوجوه المتباينه القادمه من 6
بقاع العالم كان يمكنك ان تنتبها لوجه
المفكر المصري نصر حامد ابو زيد وهو يحمل
حقيبته ويصير على عجل للحاق بموعد مع
طلابه ليحاضرهم في الدراسات الاسلاميه
للبحث والدراسه بل منفى نختار اللجوء اليه
بعد ان وجد نفسه في عين عاصفه هوجاء من
خصومه المتشددين تركهم في وطنه
لكن احكامهم ظل تطارده حتى فرقته عن زوجته
عام 1995
انا لم اعش هذه
وانا مدين اصلا في هذا ايضا للدكتوره
ابتهال يعني زوجتي يعني احنا عشناها يعني
ما عملناش يعني ايه محولنهاش لقضيه داخليه
خاصه بينا
اتفق واختلف معه كثيرون حول كتاباته عن
الشريعه الاسلاميه لم يصل الاختلاف الى حد
التكفير الا عندما اصطدمت اطروحات ابو زيد
بنفود المتطرفين
استعاده النص القراني
اهل البلاغه الاوائل ولكن استعمل مع هذه
القراءه مناهج حديثه لم تكن موضع قبول او
رضا انه ابن المدرسه الفلسفه وانه يتجاوز
المعتزل بكثير وبدا رحله البحث وهو يؤمن
بان الباحث يمتلك سؤال وان هذا السؤال هو
سؤال متحرك متغير وقال ان بدا فقال انا
ساقوم بدراسه اهم ظاهره تاويل حدث في
التاريخ الاسلامي فبدا في رساله الماجستير
بدراسه المعتزله للتعرف على العقل
الاعتزالي ثم في مرحله الدراسه الدكتوراه
اراد ان يتعرف على التاويل والعقل المؤول
عند المتصور فقام بدراسه التصوف عند ابن
عربي وبعد ان انتهى من هذا الضلع الذي
يمكن ان نسميه دراسه المؤول او الذات
القارئ انتقل الى دراسه النص فيما يعرب
بكتابه مفهوم النص
اسطنبول الدوله الرسول
اهتمامات
الدراسات الاسلاميه
ولذلك قرات الكتاب
وسالت الدكتور حسن حنفي هل يعرف فكره وقال
انه يتابعه جيد فقلت له اكتب لنا مقاله عن
فكر
ومبادرات الدكتور
نصر حامد ابو زيد
دخل في مواجهه صريحه مع كل محاولات ادلجت
الاسلام او التوظيف النفعي للاسلام فهو
كان يقول بشكل صريح هل الاسلام اشتراك كما
قيل وكما كتبه مصطفى السباعي ام ان
الاسلام هو راس مالي كما يطرح في اللحظه
التي كان يكتب فيها الدكتور نصر حامد ابو
زيد كثيره الضجه
[موسيقى]
وهذا زاد من حرصي على العلاقه به باعتبار
انني اعتبرته
مبادره جديده في الدراسات الادبيه
واللغويه للقران
وما كانش في اي حملات ضده ايه السبب اللي
ولع الدنيا
مش في افكاره واجتهادات لا اللي ولع
الدنيا كتاب صغير قد كده اسمه نقد الخطاب
الديني هذا الكتاب كان في مناح عام في مصر
في ذلك الوقت كانت شركات توظيف الاموال
اللي تسمى
اسلاميه انتقد
اسلوب علمي
الخطاب الديني اللي كان في ذلك الوقت
مناصر او بيستخدم
للدعايه لشركه توظيف الاموال
[موسيقى]
في سبعينات وثمانينات القرن الماضي دعت
شركات توظيف الاموال المصريين الى ايداع
اموالهم لديها لاستثمارها كبديل عن البنوك
بالزعمي انهم قادرون على تقديم ارباح اعلى
وان فوائد البنوك نوع من الربا
من بين شركات توظيف الاموال كانت شركه
الريان والسعد هما الاشهر وانتهى الحال
بتلك الشركات الى الحل وملاحقه اصحابها
قضائيا لعجزهم عن سداد اموال المذيعين
رانيا كاظم
1992 تقدم مصر ابو زيد برسالته نقد الخطاب
الديني و بعدد اخر من مؤلفاته الى اللجنه
العلميه بجامعه القاهره للحصول على درجه
الاستاذ في الدراسات الاسلاميه بكليه
الاداب
الاستاذ المساعده
ناقص ايه ناقص من خارج
الكميه بتضم ثلاثه
كان فيها عبد الصبور شاهين
احد كتب نصر ابو زيد
في موضوع وما كانش يقصد يعني عبد الصبور
شاهين
بدقه يعني
اقتصاد الاسلامي وشركات توظيف الاموال فهو
قال انه
بيخدعوا المواطن البسيط باسم الدين
استاذ عبد الصبور شاهين
مستشار
هندي
في واحد
هو برده نفس القصه كده احمد عينه مستشار
عنده في في
الشركه يعمل يعمل على اساس ان هو
ينقذوا الشركه يعني
[موسيقى]
تجربه الدكتور نصر حامد ااا ابو زيد تجربه
مختلفه
لان هو كان استاذا للدراسات الاسلاميه
وبالتالي هو يتحدث في مجال تخصصه العلمي
وتخصصه الاكاديمي اثنين هو لم يقل شيئا
يمص صحيح الدين ولا يمص ثوابت الاسلام
ولكن
قضيته بدات وبتثبت رؤيه ان كثير من
القضايا والامور بتبدا في البدايه كائن
شخصيه وكائن خاصه هو كتب مقالا في جريده
الاهالي ينتقد في ان استاذ جامعي يتحول
واستاذ في الدراسات الاسلاميه يتحول الى
المستشار الى شركه تنهب اموال المصريين
لم يغفر له الدكتور عبد الصبور شاهين
فجاءت الترقيه حين تقدم الى ترقيه
للاستاذيه كان ينبغي على لجنه الترقيات
اذا ارادت ان يكون
في خير في البحث العلمي انه لم يكن يجب ان
يدفع بانتاج نص ابو زيد الى عبد الصبور
شاهين لانه هناك معركه قديمه بينهما لكن
دفعه اليه
كفره
لم تقتصر المساله على رفض عبد الصبور
شاهين ترقيه مصر لتخرج تفاصيل القضيه من
لجنه الترقيات الى عناوين الصحف
مسالته بطريقه
غير علميه والدعائيه
هو ظهور قصه انه زملائه رفضوا ترقيته في
كليه الاداب
وبدا فهمه هويدي
يعلق في مقالاته على همم ما يسميه
الدراسات العلمانيه ااه والدراسات
الاشتراكيه
ونصر محمد ابو زيد لم يكن علمانيه ولا
استشراقيه دخلت جريده الاهرام من خلال
المفكر الراحل لطفي الخولي على الخط دفاعا
على ناصر ابو زيد فاصبحت هناك معركه
للاستخدام الفكري والسياسي وتحولها من من
ازمه متعلقه بترقيه استاذ جامعي الى همم
مساحه الاستخدام بين التيار الذي اا يعني
يسمى طيارا علمانين او المدنيه وبين تيار
همم
محافظ او متشدد او اصولي همم يدعي اندفاع
عن المقدسات الدينيه فورا افضل
[موسيقى]
تقدم في يونيو من عام
1993 المحامي محمد صميد عبد الصمد واخرون
بدعوى قضائيه طالب فيها بتفريق مصر ابو
زيد عن زوجته الاستاذه الجامعيه ابتهال
يونس
تو يو
[موسيقى]
شو اول اول
الاسلامي هو في نفسه مختلف وهو في نفسه
متصارع ولكن عندما ياتيه صوت يريد ان يخذ
العقل يشعر بالتهديد فيتكتل لمواجهه هذا
الصوت وهذا الصوت قام به بشكل جيد وبشكل
علمي وبشكل منهجي رائع
ولو كتب لهذا الصوت ان يستمر لو كنا في
نقطه افضل لدينا مدرسه فكريه
العلميه في قابليه هذه الايه او هذه مثل
ما يفعل المختصون فيما بينه اااه
لقبلته وكنت انا من انصار فكره حسن حنفي
بانه كان الاصل ان لا تناقش هذه المسائل
في الاعلام
ولكن رد علينا ناصر محمد قال انا لم
اناقشها في الاعلى الذي ناقشه وهم بدؤوا
بالحمله عليه سواء من الناحيه العلميه في
تقرير عبد الصبور شاهين
وطردت الى الرد عليه وظليت ملتزم بالجنب
علمي حتى هجموا علي في الاعلام الاول محمد
بكتب
وخطوات في النوامع
اول مره
في مصر يعني مهتمش ويوم صدور هذا الحكم
الاول كان مصر بيتسمم وسام
في تونس
ورجعوا يعتبر من الموضوع خلص يعني
لم تكشف الصحف حيثيات حكم المحكمه
الابتدائيه برفض دعوه تفريق الا ان مقربين
من ابو زيد قالوا ان الدعوه خالفت الماده
الثالثه من قانون المرافعات والتي نصت على
ان تكون لمقدمى اي طلب او دفع مصلحه قائمه
في طلبهم
مرتد ان مرتد
على الرغم من رفض المحكمه للدعوه القضائيه
تقدم عبد الصمد بطعن على الحكم مستندا الى
مبدا عرف لدى الفقهاء بمبدا الحسبه
[موسيقى]
دعوه الحسبه اللي هي الواحد يبقى بيرفع
قضيه لمصلحه المجتمع ودي المصريين
والجمعيات الاهليه بالذات بتعملها كثير
انها تروح بتطلع نينا في قرار الحكومه
انها تشيل الشجر عشان حمايه البيئه عشان
الصحه دي نوع من الحسبه للصلح العادي طيب
ده كان مقبول يعني ما حدش مجلس الدوله طعن
في ده لانه مش بيتدخل في حرمه الحياه
الخاصه اللي مخليه ربنا
يهديه القضيه لجوه المضطر ولا جاءت الى
هذه القضيه لانها حسبه والحسبه برده كفايه
واذا لم يكن به احد في المجتمع هذه ما
المجتمع كله ومن حقي انا كشخص كمواطن ان
ادفع عن نفس الاسم حيث لم يقم احد بهذا
الرجل
في طعنه على حكم المحكمه الابتدائيه
استشهد عبد الصمد باقوال بعض فقهاء المذهب
الحنفي
لاثبات ان دعوته لتفريق ابو زيد عن زوجته
هي نوع من الحسبه التي ياثمه هو هو
المجتمع اذا تركها بحيث تكون له وللصالح
العامه مصلحه قائمه في تلك الدعوه تتمثل
في دفع الاثم عن نفسه وعن المجتمع
لدعوه الحسبه في مصر لكن كان في نص قاعد
ترتيب المحاكم الشرعيه في حاله غياب اي نص
ترجع لارجح الاقوال همم ما سبب نسب الامام
ابي حنيفه هم بقى الفريق اللي قرر انه
يدمر او يصفي الدكتور نصر حامد ابو زيد
راح مستند على النص ده وقال لك تفريق
ضد تيار
ابتليت به مصر من بعيد
في القسم الذي يشتغل في المجال العلمي
وجواز هذا التفسير او ذلك
بالمقاييس العلميه اللغويه والاسلاميه
والجزء الثاني
من جهه الصحراويين الاسلاميين والذين
يقولون انهم يدافعون عن الاسلام
ويستحثون الدوله
ويجنونها احيانا لان بدات تؤثر في الاعراب
عن عن عن ان القضاء هو المكان الصالح
[موسيقى]
متابعه هذه القضايا او الحكم فيها
قبل عمل السميده عبد الصمد في المحاماه
نشرت صحيفه الاهرام المصريه عام
حركه التعيينات القضائيه في مجلس الدوله
المصريه
وتضمنت تعيينه رئيسا لاداره الفتوى لوزاره
الزراعه
لماذا
قال لانني اخشى منصب القضاء فانا اعلم ان
قاضيا في الجنه وقاضي النار
في عامي
و1988
ابرمه وزاره الزراعه تعاقدات على استيراد
كميات ضخمه من الذرات الصفراء عن طريق
احدى شركات عائله الريان التي اشتهرت
بالعمل في مجال توظيف الاموال
في الحادي عشر من نوفمبر عام
1988 بدات السلطات المصريه التحقيق مع
اسره الريان بتهمي مخالفه قوانين توظيف
الاموال وتهريب الاموال للخارج وتقديم
الرشاوه لموظفي حكومه
اثبتت التحقيقات ان الصفقات وزاره الزراعه
مع الريان انطوت على العديد من المخالفات
التي اشتهرت في الصحف بقضيه فساد الذره
الصفراء
في الرابع والعشرين من نوفمبر عام
اعلن سميد عبد الصمد عن تاسيس مكتبه
الخاصل المحاماه لكن لم تكشف الصحف تاريخ
استقالته من منصبه
يعني قرائن او
بدل على كده انه هذه المجموعات اللي لها
مصالح لدعم الطيارات
الاسلام السياسي هي اللي كانت داعمه ل- اا
دعوى ومين اللي رفع 75 80 دعوه على اهم
الكتاب والمفكرين في مصر كلهم هيطلقوهم من
زوجاتهم
مين اللي عمل كده ما هم دول كلهم الطيارات
اللي يعني ما هو ماشي يعني متبرعين دي
الطيارات اللي لها اغراض من
هذه الدعوه نوع من الارهاب الفكري
في عام 2001 نشر الصحفي جمال عبد الرحيم
كتابه
الملحدون الجدد
وتضمن حوارا مع عبد الصمد اعترف خلاله
بانضمام الداعيه يوسف البدري اليه في دعوى
الحسبه والتفريق المقاومه ضد نصر ابو زيد
دي تلت العالم ده ثلث العالم مسلمين
الرابعه
اتسم بينهم ازاي
ازاي مسلم
اشتهر البدري
والفنانين قضائيا كم اشتهر بالدعوه الى
قتل المتظاهرين ضد جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
والرئيس المصري الاسبق محمد مرسي عام 2013
لاحقا نجح عبد الصمد والبدري وفريقهما في
اعاده نظر القضيه امام محكمه الاستئناف
بعد قبول طعنهم على حكم المحكمه
الابتدائيه
سلطه تبحث في قلوب الناس وجد الدكتور ناصر
ابو زيد انه من غير
الوارد ان يقدم هذه الشهادات كان نوع من
الرشوه
وفضل ان تكون المواجهه فكريه متمسكا
بارائه وطلب ان يكون النقاش علميا بالمعنى
الحقيقي ولكن طبعا همم يعني تصوراته كانت
بريئه اكثر من اللازم
في يونيو عام
1995 قضت محكمه الاستئناف بتفريق مصر ابو
زيد عن زوجته
استنادا الى حيثيات شبيهه بحيثيات قبول
الطعني على حكم المحكمه الابتدائيه
نوم
بالتوازي مع صدور الحكم
اتخذت ازمه مصر ابو زيد ابعادا اكثر خطوره
على حياته وحياه اسرته
هذا الصراع من صراع فكري داخل اروقه
الى المنابر الدينيه
واستعمل منبر
على الدكتور نصر ابو زيد داعيا الى وقفه
وقتله وغير ذلك من الامور التي اصبحت
معروفه تقريري يتضمن الاخطاء المنهجيه
الاخطاء الاكاديميه
ولا علاقه له بتكفير
ولم تقطع اعتقاد الرجل ولا اتهمته في شيء
عندما انكر شاهين تكفير ابو زيد نسي ان
التاريخ وثق تكفيره له وتحريضه ضده في
احدى خطبه بمسجد عمرو بن العاص
وتحديدا في الحادي والعشرين من يونيو عام
نصر في الوقت ده كان في 6 اكتوبر مساكن
الجامعه وكان في الدور الارضي
اي حد وطلع بقى ان ان فتوى بتاعه اهدار
برنامج
اما يطلع شيخ ويطلع فتوى مش مهم الشيخ مين
[موسيقى]
انما انا كنت شايف حراسه
ومن الناحيه الثانيه في دور ارضي في بنك
ممكن ترنيمه
انه
نصر ممكن
يدرس في جامعه
كان في عرض قبل كده
مصر ما كانش لسه وافق عليه انه يروح جامعه
في المانيا لمده سنه بس كان بعد سنه
انما احنا عايزين حاجه دلوقتي فحصل حكايه
ترتيبات انه راح جامعه
من الاسلام
وبالتالي كان اول محاضره انا القيها وكان
فيها وجمهور طبعا يعني انا مدرك ان
الجمهور جاي علشان عارف القضيه واسم ابو
زيد اصبح مرتبط بحكم قضائي بالجمهور جاي
لاسباب كبيره جدا وانا قاعد فبدات
المحاضره بالبسمله وبنطفي الشهاده
[موسيقى]
العلميه ويستفيد ايضا من الاجواء الجديده
همم التي تعرف عليها في اوروبا في جلسات
الاسلاميه والدراسات الادبيه بشكل عام صار
في وسائل الاعلام العام في الصحف وفي
المجلات
ينشر اراء عن تقدميه الاسلام وانت تقدميه
القران
وعن ان
الاسلاميين هؤلاء
يتجرون به المسائل القرانيه والمسائل
الاسلاميه في الدعوه
لرجعيتهم السياسيه
ودي
تشويه صوره الاسلام بحجه ان الاسلام الذي
يعرضونه هو الاسلام الصحيح لكن الراي
العام ما عدم مهتما بهذا الامر بقدره
اهتمامه بمساله
صلاحيات وهل من حق المحاكم المصريه ان
تتدخل في هذه المساله او لا احنا لسه في
السنه بعد حكم التفريق بنشتغل على الدفاع
اول حاجه طلبناها اننا نعدل ماده ثلاثه من
قانون المرافعات
يعني ندقق الصياغه ونقفل الثغرات اللي
ممكن تسمح انه اي حد ماشي في الشارع يرفع
قضيه على حضرتك وانت في بيتك او حضرتك
وانت في بيتك او على ابنك او على بنتك
يطلعوهم من من مراتاتهم او من ازواجكم
فالماده ثلاثه مرافعات قالت لا تقبل اي
دعوه ولا اي طلب يعني لا تقبل دي يعني
يعني دي قاعده من النظام العام وقال اي
طلب الا اذا كان صاحبه لديه مصلحه شخصيه
ومباشره وقائده
الناس العاديه كان في الوقت ده بعض الصحف
بتعمل يعني ايه استبيان في الشارع مع مع
الناس سيده همم يعني امنيه
وانا ساعتها قالت يعني انا ما اعرفش ماذا
فعل هذا الرجل وقد يكون هذا الرجل مخطئ
وقد يكون مجرم
لكن ما ذنب امراه
اذا كان زوجته متمسكه بي وفعلا ده اول
انتصار لينا بعد حكم التفريق كان القانون
ثلاثه لسنه 96 بتنظيم اجراءات دعوه الحسم
ليه اعتبرنا انتصار لانه هو قال انه
اختصاص رفع دعوى الحسبه همم
اختصاص قاصر على النيابه العامه لانه بعد
الحكم التفريق حضرتك يمكن 75 80 دعوه
اترفعت ضد نجيب محفوظ
نجيب محفوظ اترفعت ضد دعوه تفريق بينه
وبين زوجته
كبار الكتاب والصحفيين بقى بلا تسميه
استاذ مكرم محمد احمد استاذ مشعل كلهم
اترفع عليهم دعوه تفريق المثقفين والكتاب
المصريين
القانون ده انقذهم كلهم
ارسل نصر ابو زيد بيانا نشراته صحيفه روز
اليوسف
ناني اعتذر بايماني بالا اله الا الله
وبان محمد رسول الله
وبايماني بنوبل الاسلام وانسانيه مقاصدك
فانني اود ان اؤكد من جديد انني لم اقصد
بكل ما كتبت الاساءه الى الدين او الطعن
في تعليم الاسلام او قدسيه القران الكريم
او الحديث النبوي الشريف وانما هي في
التحليل الاخير اجتهادات بشريه تخطئ وتصيب
والاسلام الحنيف دينه العلم والعقل جعل
للمجتهدي المخطئ اجرا وللمصيبه اجرين
واؤكد كذلك انني على اتم الاستعداد
لمناقشه وجاءت النظر المختلفه والمغايره
اذا كان في ذلك في تلك الوجهات ما يقنعني
فانني مستعد للاخذ به لانني لا ارجو الا
وجه الله والعلم الذي ينفع المؤمنين والذي
يتفق مع صحيح الدين نص حامد ابو زيد ثلاثه
مارس 1996
[موسيقى]
وثقت هيئه الدفاع عن نصر ابو زيد بيانه في
السفاره المصريه بامستردام
ليقدموه الى النائب العام الذي ارسل
البيان بدوره الى دار الافتاء المصريه
يا اما هو يرجع بعد الاراء المجتمع فيها
يا اما يا اما الطرف الاخر محكمه تقتنع
انه تاويله ممكن يحمل على اوجه صحيح ده
اللي قال انه ما ينفعش الناس همم توتها من
مثل هذه الجريمه ويحكم عليها من غير
مناقشه مباشره ومفصله وصريحه
وقال كمان راي الامام مالك انه لو في
المعروف انه اي راي ممكن يحمل
99 واجهه على انه كفر ووجه واحد على انه
ايمان
يحمل على الوجه اللي فيه
الايمان يعني كان
مستنير ومتسامح في الفتوه بتاع الازهر
كمؤسس ظالم
لم يبدي رايه لكن في قسم كانوا يسمون نفسه
علماء الازهر وهؤلاء همم اصدروا بيانات
ادانا وهؤلاء عندهم
ميولوانيه
وظلوا حتى على هذا الاراء حتى قامت 25
يناير
انضم بعض اساتذه جبهه علماء الازهر الى
عبد الصمد والبدري ومن ابرزه هؤلاء
الاساتذه محمود مزروعه الذي اهدر دم
المفكر الراحل فرج فوده متسببا في اغتياله
عامه 1992
في الجامعه وهي اللي اخذ بها الجوائز ولا
خليها ثم فجاه تصبح هي اداه كثيره
استندت التقارير في مجملها للاعتقاد نصر
ابو زيد في مجازيه بعض التعبيرات القرانيه
وتاريخيه بعض الاحكام المستمده من القران
نصر اراد ان يستدعي هذا وعندما تحدث عن
وجود المجاز ووجود الرمل داخل القران
الكريم قال ان هذا له تاسيس اينما تحدث
هذا المستوى عندما نتحدث الان بمنتهى
القبول وبلا اختلاف بين جميع المسلمين على
ان حتى يعطوا الجيزيه على ان هذا سياق
تاريخي مونتاج هل احد يقول اننا نعطي
الفيزياء الان او ان غير المسلمه الجنيه
يتحدث عن ان هذا سياق تاريخي منتهي عندما
نتحدث عن ايات الايمان والعبيد داخل
القران الكريم هل نحن نتحدث عنها الان على
انها سياق اجتماعي منتهي اذا عدنا الى 200
سنه قبل ذلك لا يضر احد ان يقول هذا لان
هذا القران ويقولون كيف لا يقولون كيف لا
يكون هناك وهذا كان يحدث فعلا وكان طالبون
بهدف بحق شرعي الذي فعله نص انه كان سابق
للزمالك
الازهر طرح مفهوما مشابها لما قدمه نصر في
ما يتعلق بالجزيه على سبيل المثال عندما
اعلن شيخ الازهر احمد الطيب ان مصطلحاته
اهل الذمه والجزيه هي مصطلحات كان لها
سياق تاريخي وانتهى
الذي حدث وتم التحريف
للتحرير ضد النصر انه قيل بان المصري يقول
بان القران هو منتج انتهت صلاحيته
دائما كان يؤكد انا لاناقش ان القران من
عند الله او من غير عند الله انا اقول
القران من عند الله ولكن اتحدث فيه كان
رساله في بنيه لغويه في حاجه الى تحديد في
حاجه الى دراسه وفقا لطبيعتها كميه لغويه
حتى نستطيع ان نميز بداخلها ما بين
التاريخ ما بين الزمن المحدد وما بين
المعرفي الانساني الخالق ونحن حتى عندما
نقول في المعنى التاريخي حتى يكون هناك
تحرير في العباره نقول بان هناك حكم تعطل
حكم او خطاب انتهاء
قالوا انه انه هو بينكر
انه القران من عند الله سبحانه وتعالى
وانه بينكر
بيقول انه انه بشري
وبيقول انه منتج ثقافي وطبعا ده كله كان
عباره عن اجزاء يصل الى حد الجريمه
الكامله يعني لانه همم دكتور ناصر قال ايه
القران الهي المصدر
بشري اللغه والثقافه يعني الهي وينج من
عند ربنا
من عند ربنا لكن ربنا نزله بلغه مين بلغه
البشر بلغه العرب باللغه العربيه
[تصفيق]
بطعون على حكم محكمه الاستئناف للتفريق
السنده الطعون الى تعديل قانون المرافعات
وصدور قانون الحسبه وبيان النصر ابو زيد
وتعليق مفتي الجمهوريه عليه
وقعت الصدمه الكبرى في اغسطس عام
رفضت محكمه النقض الطعون الثلاثه
وايدت حكم محكمه الاستئناف بتفريق نصر ابو
زيد عن زوجته
لكن المعركه لم تنتهي
[موسيقى]
دعوه مستعجله اشكال مستعجل لوقف تنفيذ هذا
الحكم
وكان بيستند الى اولا انه
تعدل القانون
ماده ثلاثه مرافعات وبتقول انه لا يجوز
لاي شخص انه يرفع دعوه او يقدم طلب طلب
بتنفيذ الحكم الا اذا كان عنده
مصلحه شخصيه مباشره
ده نمره واحد وانه القانون ده قال
كده يبقى ما فيش دلوقتي الناس اللي رفعوا
الدعوه ما بقاش لهم صفه ولا مصلحه انهم
يطلبوا تنفيذ الحكم
واخذنا حكم التانيث نهائي
بوغكس تنفيذ حكم التفريق نهائيا
وقع عبد الصبور شاهين نفسه في شراك
التكفير التي نصبها لنصر حامد ابو زيد بعد
ما اقام يوسف البدري ضد شاهين دعوه حسبه
لتفريقه عن زوجته عام 2000 على خلفيه كتاب
ابي ادم الذي اعتبره البعض ارتدادا عن
الاسلام لكن تعديل قانون المرافعات انقض
عبد الصبور شاهين من الملاحقات التي خاضها
خصمه ابو زيد
الدكتور عبد الصبور
فيما يتصل بكتابك المشكله
بانهم سوف يستخدمون الحسبه ويرفعون عليك
قضايا
وهناك شامتون يقولون انك تقف الان في نفس
الموقف الذي وضعت فيه الدكتور نصر حامد
ابو زيد يوم ما قرات انتاجه الفكريه ونفط
ترقيته وافقت الدنيا عليه
طويت صفحه النزاعات القضائيه دون ان تطوى
صفحه التكفير والتهديدات في الصحف وعلى
المنابر
ليقرر نصر البقاء في منفاه الاختياريه
سنه 2003 كان لاول مره بعد سنوات من خروجه
من مصر كانت
المناسبه حضور ثقافي
دمشق وكان معنا المطرب الشهير محمد منير
ثم قدم اغنيات شهيره من اغنيته الوطنيه
وغيرها تاثر الدكتور نصر ابو زيد وبكى
يعني لانه
مغترب عن مصر ولا يستطيع ان يعود اليها
[موسيقى]
توته مصريه